[موسيقى]
ولمعرفه ما تحتويه عصاره الموت المتجمعه
في هذا المستنقع والناجمه عن هذا المكب
واثرها على البيئه والانسان التقينا
الدكتور جواد شقير رئيس مختبر ابحاث
المياه والتربه في جامعه القدس كم
النفايات تم اغلاقه امام المجمعات
الفلسطينيه وبقي شغال لخدمه معلقه دوميم
والمنطقه الصناعيه اللي هي الخانه الاحمر
تقريبا بيوصل مكب النفايات ما يعادل بين
الالف و500 الى 1800 طن ومرشح انه هو
يرتفع وتزيد هذه النسبه الى الفين طن
يوميا الان 70% الى 80% من هاي النفايات
هي النفايات قابله الى اعاده الى التحلل
يعني مواد عضويه كل كيلوغرام من الماده
العضويه بيعطينا تقريبا من خمسه سته الى
سته لتر من الغازات الدافئه هذا المكان
انشئ عام 1980 1981 بدون ما يعملوا له
اللي هي التغطيه للارضيات
والاكثر من ذلك ما وضعوا برك لجمع ومعالجه
المياه الناشئه عن تحلل الماده العضويه
انما تركوها تروح في الواد الان هذه
الاسره بتتجمع داخل البركه حتى تترك للشمس
انها تتبخر الشمس غير قادره على تبخيرها
لاسباب فيزيائيه متعلقه في طبيعه الماده
ماده لزجه رائحتها كريهه جدا لانها تحتوي
على ماده عضويه تتحلل تحلل لا هوائي كمان
وبالتالي بتعطينا رائحه صعبه جدا ممكن
تاثر على الجهاز التنفسي للناس في المنطقه
الان الحل اللي بيعملوه انه هم بيضخوها من
هذه البركه بيرجعوها على مجمع النفايات
حتى انها هي تاخذ وقت اطول يعني هي عمليه
تدوير زمني لكن الكميه هي ثابته